E=mc2 has got to be the most famous equation
in the world. While studying physics. I used
it countless times and saw it derived in lecture
slides. But I recently realised that I don't
think I've ever read Einstein's original paper
where he derives it for the first time, and
I'm guessing that you might not have read
it either. But given how ubiquitous the equation
is, doesn't it seem important, or at least
interesting to see its first occurrence in
the flesh, to read it for ourselves? Well,
here it is. Here's Einstein's paper from 1905,
where he first mentions the relationship between
energy and mass. The paper is only three pages
long, and it's not too difficult to understand.
So let's take a look at it. One reason why
you might not have read the original paper
before is because it was written in German.
But math is a universal language, right? So
when I first took a look at it, I was scanning
to see where E=mc2 appeared. And I couldn't
find it. To actually spot it, we need to switch
to the English translation because Einstein
never actually wrote E=mc2 in this paper.
Instead, he said it in a sentence. If a body
gives off the energy L in the form of radiation,
its mass diminishes by L over c squared. Rearranging
that sentence, the change in energy L is the
change in mass times the speed of light squared,
we often use E for energy, giving the more
familiar form E=mc2. The equation's message
is that mass and energy are interchangeable.
The title of this paper is, in English, "Does
the inertia of a body depend upon its energy
content?" we can read inertia as mass here.
It was the fourth paper that Einstein published
in 1905, a year known as his miracle year,
since the four papers revolutionised science's
understanding of the fundamental concepts
of space, time, mass and energy. The other
papers that Einstein published in 1905 were
on the photoelectric effect, Brownian motion
and special relativity. They were all published
in the same journal, the annals of physics.
This one about the mass energy equivalence
wasn't supposed to be a main attraction, it
was an addition to another paper, just more
of a quick technical note, which is why it's
so short. The paper starts off by saying that
the results of the previous investigation
led to a very interesting conclusion, which
is here to be deduced. Those results he's
referring to are from his recent paper called
On The Electrodynamics of Moving Bodies, which
presented his theory of special relativity.
He summarises a key idea from it, that the
laws of physics must be the same in all non
accelerating reference frames. The first equation
here is one from the Special Relativity paper,
so he doesn't bother deriving it again, but
it is the change in energy of a wave as seen
by a moving observer. It is the relativistic
Doppler effect that he's just discovered in
his previous paper and is excited to explore
what else it can do. L is the energy of the
light wave, c is the speed of light, and v
is the relative speed between the reference
frames. phi is the angle between the source
and the receiver. The Doppler effect is the
change in frequency of a wave for an observer
who is moving relative to the wave source.
If the source is moving in the direction of
the waves, then those will appear to be more
bunched up and have higher frequency. A common
example of the Doppler shift is when a car
siren approaches you, and you hear a frequency
that is higher than that of the emitted frequency,
and the frequency is lower as it drives away.
The relativistic Doppler shift takes into
account the time dilation effects of special
relativity since frequency and energy are
related by E=hf, the energy is also changed
by the same factor. Now that we know how light's
energy changes when viewing it from a moving
reference frame, Einstein then comes up with
a thought experiment for us. Let there be
a stationary body in the system XYZ, and let
its energy refer to the system XYZ, be E0.
Let the energy of the body relative to another
system moving with velocity v, be H0, that
moving system might be a rocket, let this
body send out in a direction making an angle
phi with the x axis, plane waves of light
of energy half L measured relatively to XYZ
and simultaneously an equal quantity of light
in the opposite direction. Meanwhile, the
body remains at rest with respect to the system
XYZ, according to the conservation of energy
and the principle of relativity. As we hit
these two equations where E1 and H1 denote
the energy of the body after the emission
of light as measured relative to each of the
two systems. These equations just say that
the energy of the body after emitting light,
plus the energy of the light pulses in each
direction, add to give you what you started
with. That's the conservation of energy. The
same is true for the moving frame of the rocket,
but the light pulses are multiplied by the
relativistic Doppler effect formula. Since
their energy will appear different to a moving
observer. E0 and H0, both describe the energy
of the same body. In E0, it's from a frame
at rest, and H0, it's from the rocket, the
difference between E0 and H0 will be the kinetic
energy of the body. Remember that according
to the rocket, it's the light emitting body
that seems to be moving at high speed, the
rocket observer thinks that they are standing
still, H0 minus E0 is the kinetic energy before
the emission of light. And H1 minus E1 is
the kinetic energy after the emission of light.
The difference between the two kinetic energies
before and after light emission is this quantity
here, which represents the energy of the light
emitted. Einstein says the kinetic energy
of the body with respect to the moving frame
diminishes as a result of the emission of
light by an amount that is independent of
the properties of the body. Moreover, the
difference in kinetic energy, like the kinetic
energy of the electron depends on the velocity.
At this step, Einstein then makes a Taylor
series expansion of this right hand side.
That means approximating this function as
a simple polynomial with respect to v over
c, and centred around zero. And approximation
like this might be helpful because once we
decompose a function into its Taylor series,
we sometimes see terms that are vanishing
in the limit, and can simplify the expression
if we are only interested in finding its limiting
behaviour. For us, the term v over c is so
small that we can neglect magnitudes of fourth
and higher orders to get the change in kinetic
energy is a half times L over c squared times
v squared. Einstein mentioned that this right
hand quantity depended on velocity, just like
the kinetic energy of an electron, which was
known to be a half m v squared. So why not
see if it fits that form? Well, it does if
L over c squared is equal to the mass. So
that's how Einstein concludes If a body gives
off the energy L in the form of radiation,
its mass diminishes by L over c squared. The
fact that the energy withdrawn from the body
becomes energy of radiation evidently makes
no difference. So that we are led to the more
general conclusion that the mass of a body
is a measure of its energy content is the
energy changes by L. The mass changes in the
same sense by L over the speed of light squared.
Finishing off Einstein say something visionary.
It is not impossible that with bodies whose
energy content is variable to a high degree.
For example, with radium salts, the theory
may be successfully put to the test. If the
theory corresponds with the facts, radiation
conveys inertia between the emitting and absorbing
bodies. Einstein was just starting to wrap
his head around the idea that a mass emitting
something massless in the form of light actually
loses mass, and that mass can be transferred
in the form of radiation between emitting
and absorbing the bodies. At first, he didn't
quite believe it, and wrote his friend about
the whole thing saying the principle of relativity
in relation to Maxwell's equations, demands
that mass is a direct measurement of the energy
of a body that light carries mass. A noticeable
decrease in the mass must then occur in the
case of radium. The thought is funny and infectious.
But whether God is laughing and has played
a trick on me, I do not know. This relation
between mass and energy has been tied to Einstein's
name and the idea of genius ever since. The
reason that you might not have encountered
the original before could be a general lack
of emphasis on the history of science alongside
teaching, but it might also be because it
was a bad proof. There are claims that Einstein's
original proof contained circular reasoning,
and there are better ways to derive the same
thing which are more rigorous and more complete.
The correctness of Einstein's first proof
is actually a controversy all of its own.
Here's a paper published last year summarising
some of the criticisms, including that Einstein's
proof contains circular reasoning, and that
it is only valid to the lowest order approximation
for kinetic energy. Discussion boards online
about this topic are surprisingly heated,
bringing in additional factors like the distribution
of credit and fame, amplified by just how
famous this equation has become. What's important
to realise, though, is that the equation itself
is correct. Disputes over the rigour of the
proof are not the same as disputes over the
result. Einstein himself perhaps unsatisfied
with his original proof went on to derive
over a dozen versions of the same result in
later papers, even more proofs of E=mc2 have
been written by others. If you don't like
Einstein's original proof, there are so many
other creative ones to choose from. In a physics
class, it might be more common to derive the
energy momentum relation, which is an extension
of E=mc2 For bodies with some momentum. Without
the first term massless photons would have
no energy. For a body at rest, the first term
disappears and we get E=mc2. And if you're
looking for mathematical rigour, why don't
take a look at Terence Tao's version of the
proof, which follows Einstein steps but in
a more mathematical language then points out
a couple of places where Einstein could have
simplified his proof. Another reason why the
original proof isn't plastered everywhere
might be because of another heated controversy
surrounding it, which has been tearing apart
physics for 100 years. That is the fight over
who deserves credit for relativity, and for
E=mc2.
I only just made it up for air after reading
all the criticisms of Einstein's proof. Before
I fell into the cavern of reading about the
other people who contributed to the idea,
and how they likely deserve more credit than
they got. Einstein wasn't the first to link
energy and mass. Even Newton himself pondered
it back in 1717. When he wrote are not the
gross bodies and light convertible into one
another, and may not bodies receive much of
their activity from the particles of light
which enter their composition? Several scientists
working on electromagnetic fields knew that
if a charged body moved through an electromagnetic
field, its mass would be affected. Poincare
in 1900, derived an expression for the conservation
of momentum in electromagnetic systems that
used E=mc2 in calculation although never explicitly
stated, Einstein seems to have been the first
to establish a mass energy equivalence that
was independent of electromagnetic fields,
and throughout his life, relentlessly devoted
time and effort to establishing E=mc2 as a
universal law applicable to all forms of matter
and energy. So in this sense, it does seem
justified to associate the idea with Einstein,
that association would come as a curse when
the public started to link the equation with
nuclear weapons. After the bombings of Hiroshima
and Nagasaki in 1945, 40 years after Einstein's
paper, E=mc2 was featured in the Smith report,
the official US government release about the
development of the atomic bomb. E=mc2 can
be used to quantify the amount of energy released
or consumed by nuclear reactions, which convert
mass into energy. If you measure the mass
of all the constituents and the mass of all
the products, and multiply the difference
by c squared, you get how much energy is released
or consumed, usually in the form of light
and heat. With c squared being such a large
number, you can see that an extraordinarily
large amount of energy can be released from
just a small amount of mass millions of times
more so than in the combustion of chemical
explosives. Whilst E=mc2 is useful for quantifying
the amount of energy released, it was not
strictly necessary for the development of
the atomic bomb, especially since the fission
process was known in 1938. It surprised me
to learn that the neutron wasn't discovered
until 1932, 27 years after Einstein's paper
and a much more crucial discovery to the development
of the weapon. Einstein himself co signed
a letter to the US president in 1939, urging
funding into research for Atomic Energy, warning
that an atomic bomb was theoretically possible.
He would later come to regret that letter.
Newton please forgive me, he would write,
not referring directly to the bomb, but for
standing on Newton's shoulders, for taking
his work and questioning its foundations,
flipping it, building upon it and driving
progress to both the good and bad consequences.
The mention of war in the story reminds us
how often scientific discoveries are tied
to both amazing and sometimes terrible consequences.
Much of the technology which has improved
our lives has also contributed to the destruction
of our climate. If you'd like to be involved
in efforts to use science and technology to
make a positive impact on our climate, then
consider this video sponsor Wren. Wren is
a website where you can calculate your carbon
footprint, discover ways to reduce it, and
offset it by funding a diverse mix of carbon
reduction projects like tree planting, mineral
weathering and rain forest protection. One
of their innovative technology projects is
centred around biochar. Dead wood from Californian
forests, which would normally be burned to
ash and release carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
is instead turned into biochar, which locks
the carbon for 1000s of years. The biochar
is then mixed with compost and sold to local
farmers to use as a natural fertiliser. Offset
your own carbon footprint on Wren. The first
100 People who sign up will have an extra
10 trees planted in their name. Thanks for
watching this video and thanks to my Patreon
supporters for making it possible. A special
shout out to today's Patreon cat of the day.
Mi-Jin.